andrew going back to it so uh forward  party how much momentum have you had  ever since you announced it it's been  tremendous because more and more people  are waking up to the reality that the  current two-party system is not working  and it's not gonna deliver what you want  no matter what you want it's not gonna  deliver unless what you want is people  to go crazy and get more and more upset  at each other that's what you want it's  going to deliver that because it's  delivering that in a hell of a way yeah  it's going to deliver that um so more  and more people go to fordparty.com  every day they sign up they volunteer uh  they donate and we have some really  exciting announcements coming up so it's  a good feeling because patrick you've  been a part of these growth stories you  know when you you have product market  fit and you feel like okay like we're  gonna grow from here that's been the  feeling